a raíz de las muestras obtenidas de 23
casos confirmados en españa' los
científicos del instituto de salud
carlos que depende del ministerio de
ciencia e innovación español han
obtenido la secuencia completa del
genoma del virus de la viruela del mono
este primer borrador determina que la
variante causante del brote en españa y
en la mayoría de los demás países fuera
de áfrica proviene de la parte
occidental del continente que es menos
virulenta que la que proviene de áfrica
central los equipos de investigación
están ahora analizando las muestras
españolas para poder compararlas con los
datos de las secuencias ya analizadas en
otros países no endémicos y conocer así
más detalles de su relación y en caso de
que las haya las diferencias la
investigación ha podido sacar el cien
por ciento de la secuenciación de los
190 mil pares de bases del genoma del
virus que son los peldaños que conforman
el adn este análisis completo permite
abrir la puerta a investigar más en
detalle de dónde proviene su
comportamiento como circula o cómo se
expande este último dato interesa sobre
todo porque aunque los expertos no creen
que haya razones para
es cierto que según un estudio hecho en
el reino unido- en 2020 el 70 por ciento
de la población mundial no está
inmunizada contra la viruela tradicional
una enfermedad erradicada oficialmente
en 1980 y cuya vacuna es hasta ahora la
única que conocemos que sea efectiva
contra la viruela del mono